one morning six years ago I woke up with
an overwhelming feeling of dread I was
beginning to feel more and more
suffocated by my life as an accountant
you see I had chosen this life but I
felt no sense of meaning no sense of
purpose not only was I unfulfilled but I
was falling apart and as I showered that
morning I thought to myself if I died
today it wouldn't be so bad I went to
work that morning i sat at my desk and I
worked on my spreadsheets like I did
every other day and at the end of the
day I packed up my stuff and I drove to
go back home
but on that specific day on the drive
back everything changed as I was going
down the freeway at 70 miles per hour a
big white truck that was in front of me
swerved to avoid a broken-down minivan I
didn't have time to get out of the way
so I crashed headfirst into the back of
the car as the windscreen shattered I
closed my eyes and braced myself as my
car was flung viciously into oncoming
traffic and then the chaos and noise the
first thought that came to my head was
thank God I don't have to go to work
tomorrow as you can see I'm standing in
front of you today I survived but in the
days and weeks that followed I thought
to myself what was the point of
surviving only to go back to a life that
made me feel like I was dying and
perhaps my case is extreme but maybe you
felt something similar a lack of
fulfillment in your job a lack of
fulfilment in your relationships just
going through the motions surviving not
quite thriving living not a full life
but a half one and after my accident I
realized that yes we're given life but
we also have to choose it for ourselves
you see we hear these stories of work
that doesn't feel like work we have
these stories of epic and pew
love and if that was true I wanted that
for myself as well as Thoreau the great
poet once wrote I wished to live
deliberately I did not wish to live what
was not life nor did I want to practice
resignation I wanted to live deeply and
suck all the marrow out of life that is
my intention I didn't know how I was
going to do it but I was determined to
figure it out a couple weeks later I
stumbled upon an interview with Oprah
and Gary Zhukov author of the New York
Times best-selling book the seat of the
soul and the core message of the book
struck rights to the center of my being
it said in order to live an authentic
and fulfilling life you have to align
your personality with your purpose in
order to live an authentic and
fulfilling life you have to align your
personality with your soul's purpose and
according to the book did three key
steps to make that happen
first uncover your personality so who
are you deep down inside what I give
values your motivations what lights you
up to use your personality to find your
purpose and turn that light from within
outward to be of service to other people
and third take steps every single day to
live that personality and that purpose
so step one uncover my personality
what would the person that I wanted to
become have to do to live a life that
was true to him off to much thought I
knew what my first act had to be I would
have to reveal to my parents that I was
what they as Africans would call evil
unnatural of the dark side
unn African I would have to reveal to my
parents that I was gay and I say this as
if it was easy but it was incredibly
difficult but I was determined to not
hide any parts of my identity
and during this time I decided to leave
my lucrative a painful accounting job
and despite strong protest for my
parents I took three months off to
travel a little travel alone to seven
Asian countries I was seeking some kind
of fulfillment some kind of awakening
and as a way to capture and share those
experiences I decided to film a video
blog and to my great surprise I
discovered my deep deep love for using
video as a way to capture and share
experiences with other people from
hunting down the most delicious ramen
and the back streets of Kyoto to trying
to recreate my very own Eat Pray Love
moment in Bali which by the way is not a
thing but I felt fulfilled I felt alive
you see video allowed me to show and not
have to tell to be and not have to
perform I could just be my most
authentic form who would you be in your
most authentic form what would you be
doing what purpose might you stumble
upon you see as I created these videos I
felt something I hadn't felt before a
deeper sense of connection to the young
Africans about watching my videos this
was step two in action
my commitment to uncovering my
personality that be write to my purpose
which is to inspire and entertain young
Africans through online video there is
nothing else in the world that I'd
rather do and what I know now in
hindsight is that it's the commitment
the commitment to wanting a better
relationship the commitment to wanting a
more fulfilling job the commitment to
finding your purpose is the most
important step as good to have a famous
German writer once wrote until one is
committed there is hesitancy the chance
to draw back but the moment one
definitely commits oneself then
Providence news to you see when we
commit we see things we otherwise
wouldn't have seen we make connections
we otherwise wouldn't have made the
moment one commits oneself than
Providence moves to
so what did I have to do next I forgot
what I was going to commit to what are
you willing to commit to today right
here right now before my accident I was
lost and hopeless as an accountant but
often my travels I felt alive I felt
fulfilled the feeling was cellular I
could feel it it was real when you
commit to uncovering your personality
and your purpose I have no doubt that
that that that is possible for you too
that brings me to step 3 discovery of
your purpose is necessary but not
sufficient to live an authentic and
fulfilling life you have to take the
steps to live it every single day so
because I like online video I set my
sights in Hollywood the lights the
camera the action but from my home in
South Africa Hollywood seemed too far
away and I could have stopped but I
didn't I had committed and what I know
now is that the most successful people
just start exactly where they are so I
started my very own YouTube show with my
best friend Lindy dedicated to sharing
stories with young Africans just like
myself everything comes from serious to
funny topics like interracial dating
what it means to be African in modern
times and even the trials and
tribulations of black girls hair and I
know it's easy to just say I'll just
start my own YouTube show but as
incredibly hard you see building an
online following it's tough but facing
my inner doubts and out of critics is
even harder to this day I still receive
homophobic comments things like why
would you share this video with me this
guy looks gay I don't want to see stuff
like that and what that has taught me is
that authenticity is not all upside you
will get beaten down in the process but
instead of feeling like I was dying I
was living a show that I created in my
bedroom was watched by over 10,000
people in 150 countries the show has
paved the brick road of blessings for me
I have so many supporters
who have become superfans some who have
even become friends and one of those
friends is Laura Laura is a super fan
from Zimbabwe and because I like to get
to know my superfans I set up a time to
Skype call with her little did I know
the impact this call would have on my
life it turns out that Laura is a little
person and that because of the show she
was inspired to side a very own YouTube
show and the little people's association
for Zimbabwe I placed a little people to
come together share stories and inspire
each other she told me that because of
my show she knew that she was enough as
Marianne Williamson the author once
wrote as we let our own light shine we
unconsciously give other people the
permission to do the same when we choose
life we unconsciously give other people
the permission to do the same I went
from being a miserable accountant and I
want to inspired you to producer with a
mission to light up other people's lives
I'm even building a company with that
mission who are you now who could you be
with the commitment to uncovering your
personality and your purpose imagine
what she could do how big you could play
and in the time since my journey began
I've learned that playing big in the
world doesn't have to mean being the CEO
of the next best startup in Silicon
Valley or Beyonce at the Superbowl we're
starting your very own youtube show we
can choose to play big every day by
having the courage to choose life by
having the courage to uncover our
personality and our purpose because once
you commit to choosing life I can assure
you that Providence will move to and
your light will give other people the
courage to do the same thank you
you